they can rob assault and burglarize cars
but elon's ex that goes too far San
Francisco officials have filed a
complaint against Twitter and are
investigating this big bright X sign on
the roof of what used to be these social
media companies headquarters in downtown
for a possible permit violation so what
is the so what does The X mean no it's
not marking the only spot in town that
hasn't been pooped on yet it's part of
Elon musk's a rebranding of Twitter to
the new company X it's like New Coke for
people too young to remember New Coke
what is that
I bought it people had stopped
installation last Monday but the sign
still popped up by Friday and evidently
the glare from the X was distracting to
Residents who were only trying to
defecate in the street
of course Police Stopped it because if
there's anything police have in San
Francisco it's a lot of free time
and this morning the sun was taken down
but maybe authorities should be focused
on more pressing issues like you know
maybe the homeless and you know it's bad
when people in tents are reporting home
invasions
of course there's the crime even
murderers are moving out because they
don't feel safe poor guys homicides are
up 23 from last year hell they're
actually running low on potential
victims robberies are up 13 it's hard to
believe there's anything left to steal
and auto theft is up 10.5 percent
but instead San Fran targets elon's sign
officials say replacing or installing a
giant one on top requires a permit
ironically something that doesn't
require a permit taking a dump on the
sidewalk
no wonder they're doing it Paul Europe
law enforcement dude rumor has it yes
um is this like is this just not ever
going to turn around is it hopeless I
mean you were here for you're you're in
your almost early 70s
um
that was amazing they thought that I was
telling the truth
but you were here when Giuliani turned
things around is that possible no no
it's not possible I don't know what
happens out in San Francisco the bigger
problem here is that all of the major
cities around the country which are Dem
run look at this and say hey that looks
like a good idea yeah and following the
exact same policy so Philadelphia New
York's getting there Memphis Baltimore
Chicago you could go on and they're all
following the same path and you know
when you see cities prioritizing taking
down letters off the top of a building
when the crime numbers are what you saw
there you know obviously it's not going
to end well but here's the real problem
we need musk yeah and I'm afraid he's
sort of like sliding into the abyss here
a little bit we don't need him
rebranding first of all you can't say I
x'd last night I X that at you what was
wrong with tweet yeah what is he
changing that for so I don't understand
and here's why we need him to hold the
line on social media and we need him to
kick Zuckerberg's ass all right
thank you
yeah
she's pointing this out to me that uh
okay when you pronounce X when it's in
the front of something like President
Chi is it she she she so if it was if
you were weren't on Twitter it would be
called
yeah in Shanghai
but yeah I don't think I don't think
I've got a flies here
how come on how many people tweet on the
toilet
so cat obviously I went there you know
so glad you did yeah you know the one
thing though
what what people don't realize is that
crime could be worse if it wasn't for
the potency of the drugs because what
people are seeing right now I think in
San Francisco and especially Philly and
in our streets of New York if anybody in
the audience are walking around the
danger of getting mugged is far less
because the drugs incapaces incapacitate
or kill the people on them it's kind
it's like a zomb it's Zombieland anyway
not so much a question as it is an
observation well the downers at least
yeah the downers the Tweakers are a
different story yeah I don't see many
tweaking on I only see downers yeah uh
yeah it's harder to take pictures of the
Tweakers they're running around all over
the place yeah yeah yeah they're very
fast this doesn't surprise me because
it's an opportunity for the government
to make money this is the stuff that
they always go after you know like I had
plates on my car when I was living one
place from another place and I had they
were following me they were like she
still has these plates we have to get
them back and I was like no I'm just I
keep visiting which is a lie obviously
but um
they got me and I think that if you
might have given them idea like they
actually might start requiring permits
to dump on the street yeah that's a
great business opportunity for them
that's why they care it's because he
didn't get the permits now that maybe
they can get more money off of him not
that's why they're making it a priority
why don't they have like um like you
have vendors in New York selling hot
dogs and they're not very good hot dogs
let's be honest but they're called uh
Street dogs right dirty dogs why don't
they have vendors selling like like mini
rolls of toilet paper and bags
because then you're just it's still
going to be all over the street there's
you're just gonna add toilet paper to it
that's not really addressing the issue
you know I was told there's no such
thing as a bad idea
that used to be a saying until you said
that thing about the toilet paper
what is the solution Aaron perini it is
too cracked out on crime so that you
know the bureaucrats and The Regulators
who are climbing up there and ripping
down the X off the top of the building
you know don't look like they're doing
something you know they're not supposed
to be doing if if you handle the crime
problem maybe you could hate the fact
that there are Regulators going up there
and taking down a big X but it's great
marketing we're all talking about it if
Elon did anything it's yeah he's
rebranding but there's an entire
conversation about the fact that he put
a giant x on a building and San
Francisco still has a massive crime
problem yeah so uh Jamie you'd love to
take down your ex
yep
that's good I haven't seen an X taken
down that fast this might have been
pretty good
[Applause]
um they would have left it if he had
just written excrement
they don't touch that
in San Francisco that is true um is it
not a little weird though Elon just uh
yesterday
that Elon tweeted yesterday everyone's
moving out of San Francisco we're not
going to we're going to stay and then
they do this that's the part I don't
understand I feel like they yeah and I
need him right I was just in San
Francisco and um there was a scientist
said if you see something like
suspicious you should say something and
I was I called right away I was like
dude there's a guy and he's pooping in a
toilet
okay
did they send somebody yeah I go I don't
think he's from around here
that's it
I think so all right good I always like
to check you never know you never know
all right up next why teen boys are
leaning right and sex robots that could
cause a fright
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else